here we are for the last three episodes
of season three we're here doing work at
Japan we've brought our friend colleague
cultural guide translator is producer
creative Lenny hi three foods three
parts ramen coffee cake is gonna be
trains vending machines walking other
b-roll eating things that aren't in
episode sweating dance wedding this is
it right like we've peaked with worth it
well we didn't get to do sushi here we
can't let's come back we're already
planning our second trip to Japan and we
have means our our first one I love it
let's go then
ramen top today we're gonna try three
rama's at three drastically different
price points to find out which ramen is
the most worth it at its price well it's
probably the most requested episode ever
I'll go up we're doing ramen I think
this is going to be an experience to
remember okay oh no no cos cacciatore
must Oh miss anandamaya ding ding - I'm
a security - dr. Armond X and X and Z
and this that's so cheap
how's that possible sell us a new name
is talita toka no contain youto mo - MO
- not certificate how much do you Irama
shmikes we assimilate material to cut it
out it's in cheap came in laconia Tanaka
Hinton and a study doorman no no there
was really kind of chief was somebody
assisted habilitated man whoa no sudden
in detail I know it's wrong food edema
sooner than II don't believe me show you
either test your video editor [ __ ]
lips ooh whoa it a mistake that if you
hunt after a minimal startup nematode
charge you would not get it what we're
also gonna be having the gear today we
hear about how they're made soda no
longer yeah once I show pattern on the
engines humming is the experts ooh the
thing would have could only Toki Dan is
saying colonies in Oaxaca meanwhile
kibbutz dentists okuni
Mira Luton Ashwini Kumar today at the
Tomeo
Texas una mas de la strategy mas de
tomate era una de abril heated dinara
better visual a tip toe step Nana
interrogatively like to be dead [ __ ]
with a ramen in America but in Japan is
there anything that we should know
before we eat the ramen what's cute
about the grass first meal in Japan I'm
ready
is there anything we should say
it's not like you much more time without
Okemah you got vacuum and I'm like thank
you for this meal I'm so happy
ooh airplane Steven no Japan Steven
awaken oh man
heck the bowl you know what I love about
noodles no much french fries you can't
just eat one french fry
yes they're two kinds of people be able
to do this single try or people who do
the claw fry and ramen is a mandatory
cloth it's important for Billy in ramen
Oh
her belly is like bacon had bacon
parties are working on omega-3 stock -
Rita
giving the counter many other bye to her
yes oh no mama you go putting are you
stupid
you see this did you get that motorcycle
right and you got that selling 300 yen
ramen but how many ramen to get to sell
to buy a motorcycle
what sorcery is so you know you owe more
more MORE
Oh Fourier and Adam format and you also
eat some gyoza even an ambulance
oh my god
that high-five so many things happening
in your mouth yeah it's seared on one
side and completely soft on another the
gyoza right in the mouth is very
delicious I got those my Rin for the
win-win
I don't know what I was expecting for
every hundred yen but that was like top
bowl of ramen I've had well can't you
get 300 yeah I mean like sweet olives in
the state Atok Oh give me four um in
fact one two three Robin Branagh fact
it's a way you have to do it Japan is
now home to at least 30 different types
of regional ramen variety you would have
to invest some serious time to
experience every ramen hey does my body
roll I took dance classes two point
eight out of ten Japanese the soba
noodles done the only she showed us to
the know up some of the hills every
dollar so it's about what a customer
Emma's so many ramen places in Japan how
did you want to differentiate from other
places to talk ah sweet you know so
could I talk about muscle Gina hostal de
turista there Matson you only one
manometer state autonomy City a
pseudonym oh no it's Kristina's gonna be
no phony new you know Julian suit toe a
kind of sleep sorry no sleep stone yeah
okay no sleep yet he Nicodemus a so no
Connie Adam greenie a triple toe see
Utah and solitary their resources so
they are tato Kenobi no hole they sleep
optimally - Tara yeah we have you on do
you know there's no come communicates
with the Turkish a man may know you the
Hajime mashed potato he oh no not Xterra
Silk Road own greenhorn you get there
without it
naraku's animals anymore it's Kaiba
Espino
ibérico butanol tabara terrorism no la
veta no los únicos no thos terminó en mi
Toto karate chop suey
stir occasionally who powdered cocoa and
a hawk or no [ __ ] on no hasaki mama II
don't - nada Snellen Honorius and less
freedom with the considers belonging
cappuccino hustle is really sweet and
wanna pursue excuse me I gotta thank you
looks awesome this is incredible because
during the broth first is that shoyu
ramen
[Music]
well yeah excuse me one second what it's
very very good but you knew that right
okay tell me what days like give me two
words primordial soup flavors colliding
in space until life is born that's what
this soup is can I tell you my favorite
part of this soup are the noodles in how
perfect they are for slurping chewing
containing the truffle flavor I've never
had a more perfect noodle I'm gonna have
a little bit of pork whoa the pork oh my
god the fat on that was unbelievable
there's something so comforting about a
bowl of soup and noodles you know just
like a warm hug
mmm this is what the ramen is like
eating a bowl of ramen is like me doing
this nothing like that truffle was a
very strong flavor mm-hm so sauce a very
strong flavor to be able to take all of
these powerhouses and have them get
along is not easy in the best part is
that you just get to steam your face
over it the whole time I think my face
is gonna taste pretty good after this we
don't and the soup is gone boss is the
boss of them all just like me I wonder
if I was supposed to shake it you may
ask create was I supposed to shake this
I don't think so
oh yeah I was yeah
oh my goodness it's chunky Cheers
that's nice it's like drinking a cake
Ramnath back Raman effect
Batman my magician Raman actually is
believed to originate from China
mm-hmm I mean I like knowing where
things come from I actually don't know
where we're going we are going to gang a
Tokyo base of course menu the main
course it's the ramen Oh like multi
worth menu yeah it's a three-course menu
is there trouble no truffle oh no caviar
no no caviar hey oh my god again a Tokyo
a ownership like idiot for most of us a
cure of telling me she didn't watch it
very cope with a peashooter no exception
of course she made tea mascot manga
geocode shoyu ramen do you mean you this
did you know Chianti Kikuyu terracotta
what about Nikon's buckets we have a
Eric yesterday you had a push noticed or
undetectable you cannot rely on we said
only cut I did you have chosen it knows
them there what they carry took it scary
data element never the Cairo usual
variously not precise O'Connor Jacuzzi
Otonashi menara event being darling a
little solution engine I cannot come by
a mother then Sangha ago that either you
know son Chicago that either you Suraj
that this is one of my favorite dishes
in Chinese it's alive a chicken because
it makes me salivate I like that yeah
eat it up math is very much
[Music]
tender Viscountess chicken salad
I mean eaten some bad Rosa yato Corrigan
Olam haba h-monster
a cranky so state nominate hola Marco
here the many a guitar backstage even
Vega Coronel Jocasta shows good man the
meeting he joining the schedule tab is
right the choreo chosen is famous there
my mother database video got a man Wow
sorry playing operation
I do appreciate a course that makes you
not eat quickly
oh that's thumbs it's like little water
balloons of tasty fish oh it gets better
the deeper you go hmm you're splashing
alone oh you got juice on my personal
Iseman I'm sorry
Tamila hey Beauty cook with that llama
he does it
now this is actually something I was
extremely excited for I thought I would
have to actually go to Spain to
experience this for the first time cool
Booth's climatic chosen to go sigh I
thought pantyhose Hassan I try though Oh
God ah like that yeah oh nice oh yeah
I'm dialed in how do you say wow in
Japanese boy boy
oh that's a nice has like the flavor of
bacon but the texture of State are you
advertised mm-hmm trouble - no because
they're not also you gotta mess in there
jo soo push them aside
[Music]
very good when you cook up I believe
with a visual they have to pass into law
Kotaro stop oh hey Tom this washer now
can it get there ma who are they a knows
your name
they are Moscow media manager today you
do get this so they would have a real
stylist man couldn't oh my dear Michelle
take to the fire that's awesome how many
swipes should we do until it starts to
curl right three thank the tongue
texture is kind of Awesome I did think
is it gonna be weird for me to press
something else is telling against my own
time but no I'm really into it like I'm
French kissing my food mmm yes i pot is
every limb family Thanksgiving I'm just
gonna have a piece of the shoulder oh
that is nice that is like a kiss yeah
yeah I made one for you Oh
mingi Jeremy Lapidus Manjeet a mobile
got scooter on this unit and I think at
10 names the Ishikawa Jukes a hostile
you interested in oh they're so no jokes
ni the new home economist a kanji dancer
named Corey 100 - imagine even rockier
see they were amino Cordia solution
cordillera darwin tipo de menos de vida
con la imagen geodon juvy or a
low-budget SCADA shiranai hito Atteberry
Kavita know a secret octave a Sheboygan
have a mask on a three-day meeting
instacart that the secret of the unit
I
[Music]
the broth is also refreshing think about
that soy sauce and it's refreshing oh
[Music]
they have an awesome texture it has a
lot of chew to it but it's not the same
as just like an el dente spaghetti
noodle no it snaps really easily I'm
gonna try the pork
okay oh oh there's the Jew oh that's
awesome
there's something about a bowl of ramen
that has like a lot of momentum to it as
a meal it just continuously evolve as
you eat more this is like a massage when
you're getting a massage you're just
like oh yeah oh no I mean the most humid
place I've ever been and all I want is
more hot noodle soup
so this pulley she came out dr. Gracia
did a shadow shadow it's like full
circle they go hmm oh my god just when I
thought the progression of comforting
hot broth a things couldn't get better
this is like the pinnacle this is home
guys I'm so happy right now I'm in a
food coma I'm like a food Cobra I've
been struck with the ramen lightning
also a snake bite if I came back to
Japan Rin Rin would be the first place I
would go to Ceuta would be the place I
couldn't leave without going to so suta
is my were that winner my worth the
winner
I watched the 84 opinion prix fixe menu
again yay I want to but I will say my
work that winner goes to the 900 yen
shoyu ramen as it was really a winner I
can't go through leave me just like sit
down in front of yota master in the
state
hold it I don't lose you with a winner
rinrin so this is just part 1 of 3 for
our Japan adventure
these are alert what do we have to eat
before we leave everything okay we will
eat everything
oh yes